>> Tucker: EXPOS ON MSNBC GUESS
WHAT HE WAS TALKING ABOUT?
CAN YOU GUESS?
ONE THING THAT BRINGS JOY TO HIS
MISERABLE EXISTENCE AND THAT'S
WAR, OTHER PEOPLE BURNING EACH
OTHER TO DEATH.
MAX BOOT ANNOUNCED A NEW
ESCALATION IN HIS NEW FAVORITE
WAR, THE WAR IN UKRAINE.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I THINK THE KEY HERE IS WE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE
MAKING A MISTAKE IN THE WAY WE
THINK ABOUT THE WAR BECAUSE WE
KEEP THINKING ABOUT IT AS THEIR
WAR.
THE UKRAINIANS ARE FIGHTING.
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT IT AS OUR
WAR.
WE'RE NOT PROVIDING GRAY EAGLE
DRONES THE UKRAINIANS NEED,
WE'RE NOT TRYING AS MULTIPLE
ORANGE POCKETS AS THEY NEED.
ALL OF US COLLECTIVELY CAN BE
AND SHOULD BE DOING MORE BECAUSE
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND THIS IS
OUR FIGHT THAT THE UKRAINIANS
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES OF.
>> Tucker: IT'S OUR WAR.
HEAR THAT PEOPLE OF DUBUQUE, BAN
GORE, GULFPORT, SPOKANE?
IT'S YOUR WAR, NOT THEIRS.
THE WEIRD THING, DESPITE THE
FACT IT'S OUR WAR, MAX BOOT IS
STILL IN THE MORNING JOE STUDIO
WEARING SOFT SHOES.
SO DESPITE THIS WAR'S WORLD
HISTORIC IMPORTANCE AND OUR OWN
PERSONAL OWNERSHIP OF IT MAX
BOOT IS NOT ACTUALLY FIGHTING
HIS WAR.
NOR, EVEN MORE STRANGELY, IS MAX
BOOT SENDING HIS OWN SALARY TO
FUND OUR WAR WHAT HE'S DOING IS
PROMOTING OUR WAR.
THIS IS HARDLY THE FIRST WAR IN
BOOT'S LONG AND NOT AT ALL
VARIED CAREER.
HE HAS DEMANDED AMERICANS GO TO
WAR IN A VARIETY OF COUNTRIES,
SYRIA, MA RAN, HOT WAR AGAINST
NORTH KOREA EVEN A WAR AGAINST
SAUDI ARABIA.
IF U.S. ARMED FORCES MADE SHORT
WORK AGAINST A HARDENED GOON
LIKE SADDAM HUSSEIN IMAGINE WHAT
THEY COULD DO AGAINST THE SADY
FAMILY BOOT ONCE WROTE AND WAS
IMAGINING IN GREAT DETAIL.
THAT NEVER HAPPENED, WE NEVER
INVADED MECCA.
TOO BAD.
SO HE MOVED ON TO CALLING FOR
THE MILITARY OCCUPATION OF
PAKISTAN.
NUCLEAR ARMED PAKISTAN, LET'S
OCCUPY IT.
AND THEN SO MALL I CAN'T OUR
WARS TOO, IN 2011 CALLED FOR WAR
AGAINST LIBYA AND HILLARY
CLINTON DID IT.
AND BOOT WAS ONE OF THE MAIN
CHEERLEADERS FOR OUR WAR DEFENSE
IRAQ.
ONCE WE REMOVE SEDAN WE CAN
IMPOSE IN BAGHDAD TO GO INTO THE
ONE WITH KABUL IN THE MIDDLE
EAST.
IS THIS AN AMBITIOUS AGENDA?
WITHOUT A DOUBT.
DOES AMERICA HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO CARRY IT OUT? ALSO WITHOUT A
DOUBT.
SURE.
WE CAN AFFORD IT.
IT WILL BE EASY.
NOW, TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
MORE THAN A PARALLEL DEAD PEOPLE
LATER, HOW DID MAX BOOT'S
PREDICTION WORK OUT?
DON'T AS